this little box is part of a billion
dollar network no one uses it's called a
helium miner and i was gifted it by a
friend who told me that it would pay me
every day just to sit on a shelf how
radio waves magical thinking i honestly
didn't care it was free for me because
it was a gift i'm heavily in debt from
the 10 million studio obviously and so i
had nothing to lose and fast forward
four months we finally have the results
and they aren't great i've made 22
dollars with this little thing which is
a 20th of the cost of the actual machine
it retails for about four hundred
dollars which means if i had paid for it
i'd break even about six years but even
worse the daily rewards of the helium
miner have been falling fast partly
because of the discovery that most of
the revenue of this network come from
other miners buying more miners and
finally it looks like it's collapsing
with users complaining very loudly on
reddit and things just look really bad
and today i want to tell the story of
how that happened how this little
company helium grew a billion dollar
organization building a network
no one uses
helium was a company that originally
started without the idea for a crypto
coin it was first a company trying to
help build the internet of things you
guys have all heard that buzzword before
right internet of things or iot it's
basically the trend of putting bluetooth
in your toothbrush radio sockets in your
socks basically connecting everything
with the internet even things you
wouldn't expect like this ring on my
finger right here right now it's selling
health data to some overpaid pharma rep
as we speak that's iot and the point is
if you're going to connect everything to
the internet these iot devices which are
much smaller usually have different
needs than something like i don't know
your phone
you don't need to transmit large amounts
of data you're dealing with tiny
batteries and you need these devices to
work over long distances which is why
helium uses a special frequency range
called lorawan also known by its much
catchier name long5 and you don't need
to fully understand longfi to just know
that helium set out to kind of catch
this wave of internet of thing devices
but as they set out to build this
network there was a big problem because
how can you afford to build a huge
network without people paying for it
first and on the other hand how do you
get people to pay for you to build a
network without building it first it's a
classic chicken or egg problem and
helium struggled with this until they
found out about crypto and devised a way
to do both at the same time they did
this by creating a crypto token called
helium network token or hnt it works in
two ways on the one hand it rewards
people who set up hot spots that's on
the supply side and on the other hand if
you want to use the network you buy h t
and spend it on the demand side for data
credits which is simply a tiny packet of
data and the idea was early adopters who
set up little hot spots like this would
make lots of agent t which in the future
would be valuable as more and more
people needed to buy these data credits
it all sounds pretty good right so
what's the catch well for a long time
this really was the rocket fuel that
propelled the helium network and it was
pointed to as a real use case of crypto
i'm sure you've heard before like what
do we actually use crypto for well
oftentimes people would point to helium
network as a great example of real-world
use cases of crypto because a single
crypto coin was bootstrapping an entire
wireless network no small feed and for a
while things were going great hundreds
of thousands of regular people were
setting up and spreading the word of
wireless hot spots and of course passive
income this is the best way to make
passive income passive income passive
income and i can't stress enough how
much of the adoption of these helium
miners were due to thoughts about
getting rich and passive income
initially payouts were eye-watering it
was a lot of money some miners were
making hundreds of dollars if not a
thousand dollars a month just from one
miner and if you consider that each of
these cost about four hundred dollars it
wasn't hard to see why many people
quickly ordered more and then more
because they're literally little money
printing machines and demand for these
machines grew so fast that it actually
became impossible to order them for a
while they were just out of stock people
even joined waitlists that were over six
months long for these things but
eventually these supply issues were able
to be worked out and the supply of these
little guys exploded just in the year of
2021 they started the year with 14 000
of these hot spots deployed and they
grew that to 450 000 in one year that's
over 3 000 hotspots a day right now they
have 900 000 hot spots which by anyone's
standard is impressive however behind
the scenes trouble was brewing the first
sign of trouble is when helium started
to reach a saturation point in the
market for hot spots basically helium
operates on a grid system where you're
incentivized to provide coverage in high
usage areas but if you have too many
people around you it hurts your profits
so in an area like this it really isn't
profitable this made it so that more and
more people were competing for
increasingly smaller shares of profit as
the helium network exploded and that
might have been okay if on the demand
side helium had been seeing increasing
adoption you know selling the actual
product of connecting the internet of
things but unfortunately that's not what
was happening by looking at the data
that the helium network themselves
provide we see absolutely abysmal rates
of adoption remember that in 2021 the
number of hotspots went absolutely
parabolic as you can see here and one
would hope that usage would follow but
looking at the data credits used we see
a different story now i'm going to have
to explain what this chart means but
basically this is the entire revenue of
the network the data credit usage but
not every part of this chart represents
actual demand for helium because there
are several ways you would use data
credits and helium for example it costs
10
in data credits for example just to set
up one of these mining hotspots but that
isn't actually someone connecting an
internet of things device and the same
is true if you want to change the
location of this device it costs another
10
you can also be charged fees for using
the network and there are all these
proofs about like if your hotspot is
where you say it is but none of this is
actually the system doing what it's
designed to do which is connect these
devices instead that category of data
credit usage belongs to the data
transfer category this you can see in
yellow and if we take a close look at
this chart again
you could hardly see the actual usage of
the network in comparison with all the
insane amounts of data credits burned
for everything else this means a few
things actual demand for this network is
almost non-existent literally in june of
this year it was reported that the
actual demand revenue for helium was
only 6 500. this was reported by the
generalist and it's hardly enough money
to justify a 1 billion valuation now the
ceo of helium amir haleem responded to
these accusations arguing that while the
numbers are true they weren't fair
because the total revenue of the network
is insanely high 54 million dollars over
its lifetime but i think he's confusing
things here because we all know that the
helium network is being used a lot the
problem is who's using it this whole
adoption scenario by real people we've
been promised isn't happening instead
it's all the miners who are using the
network of other miners for example in
the last 30 days you could argue helium
made 1.8 million dollars in network fees
but the actual demand side of these fees
was only 2 000
meaning
0.1
of the network revenue is from actual
internet of things usage which is just
horrible and understanding this starts
to make sense of why miners were
actually making so much money early on
it wasn't because people were actually
using the network it's because other
miners were onboarding thousands of new
hotspots a day and paying tons of fees
it was sort of like a ponzi like system
where old investors were paid from new
investors and once the market got
saturated it was all doomed to fall
apart and many of the investors who got
involved for those passive income dreams
are now left with expensive plastic
boxes that may never pay off that's of
course assuming this long fight dream
doesn't work out because some optimists
will argue that the reason long fight
hasn't been adopted yet is because no
one was building products for long five
when it wasn't a thing now that it's a
thing people are gonna build the
products and adoption's gonna grow in
the next five years that's their
argument but i have to say i'm a bit
skeptical given the unit economics of
helium because think about it on the one
hand their pitch is that their data is
way cheaper 360 times cheaper according
to their ceo on the other hand the
amount of data helium wants to sell you
is by design tiny because of the
frequency band so you're selling a tiny
product and you're selling it 360 times
cheaper
how do you become profitable with that
you have to be servicing absolutely
massive numbers of devices and i'm just
not convinced that's going to happen
because i already own plenty of internet
of things devices and most of them just
use bluetooth or 2.4 gigahertz wi-fi i
don't need long-fi and i guess this all
begs the question how if this data was
sort of always public did we miss this
for so long how did helium manage to
convince so many people that they were
on the cusp of being successful well
it's on this front that it turns out the
helium team may have been misleading
customers because for a long time helium
advocates would point to key
partnerships as a sign of real-world use
right around the corner they advertised
two really important companies in
particular lime and salesforce both
recognizable and large brands however it
was recently reported to mashable that
these partnerships weren't really real
at all the scooter company lime says
they only tested the product three years
ago and part of the condition was that
they couldn't use their name for
promotional material because it wasn't a
real partnership it was like a trial and
according to the verge salesforce also
wasn't in a real partnership with helium
they say quote helium is not a sales
force partner and that they don't use
the technology so
oops now once again i have to tell you
that helium responded to this and said
it's all a misunderstanding and they
just made a mistake but on this front
i'm not going to give them the benefit
of the doubt i think it's far too
convenient that they were able to use
these large brands to make themselves
look good and i ultimately i just think
they're upset they got caught now with
that you're sort of caught up to speed
with helium as of now and the question
of course is now what they're obviously
in trouble they have a huge network with
hardly any real customers but they do
have a lot of loyal miners so what's
next for them they're pivoting they want
to move into another network category
with potentially more adoption that is
5g and like last time they want this to
be rolled out by their faithful
investors who built their first big
network the catch of course is that you
can't use your old device for 5g you
need to buy a new device and it's much
more expensive like five times more
expensive and from here it kind of gets
complicated they set up some sub-dials
they created a new token to represent
this but even so it seems like there are
people willing to go along with this
ride too because already 2 000 5g
hotspots have been set up in 47 states
it's pretty shocking given how bad their
rewards are right now that people are
just dumping more money into their new
project but either way i think more than
anything this shows how good crypto is
at getting buyers before demonstrating
real demand for a product it shows how
people ignore actual fundamental value
when faced with the enticing opportunity
of passive income and it also shows how
much early adopters just want to see
those 100x gains that may or may not
come we may never know for years whether
helium's plan to bootstrap a wireless
network from scratch will have worked
but what we do know is they certainly
aren't the ones who paid for it and to
be fair neither am i i didn't pay for
this thing so in a way i'm not too upset
i'll probably go plug it back in and uh
make my pennies until either i'm a
millionaire or it stops being worth the
electricity that it uses but for those
of you thinking of jumping in investing
in helium and these crypto schemes that
are going to change the world this is a
really cautionary tale just because you
build it doesn't necessarily mean
customers will come